Yellowjackets season two is almost here
and there are so many questions let's go
through them who was the girl they
hunted down in the first episode now
that she's dead will Jackie be the first
person they eat and how will the hunter
character she saw in her dying dream
influence the rest of the story well
Jessica Robert's death come back on
Misty and what was up with that room she
had in her basement what about Adam was
there more to his backstory and will the
investigation into his death lead to the
survivors
where did hobby go after he went missing
during Doom coming is there more to
Travis's death and what was Nat right
about was it a cult led by Lottie that
kidnapped her and why is what's
happening with Lottie and taisa
connected to the supernatural or are
there rational explanations for
everything how many other survivors are
there and what does that say about our
first question